[Music]
i am a neat freak and a minimalist but
my husband is not and drives me crazy
his nightstand dresser drawers and
bathroom sink are piled with rarely used
things to the point where i just want to
throw all of his stuff into a dumpster
help
hmm well don't throw your husband's
things into a dumpster that's theft
that's step one
wait a minute
oh man what it's funny because this is a
this is bothering peg
it's not bothering her husband
and it's often that we project our own
judgments and frustrations onto someone
else i'm not saying
that there isn't some work that her
husband needs to do maybe there's a you
know maybe there's an unhealthy
situation if that's the case then yes
like you've gotta you've gotta approach
your husband about it but
dude the minute we come out with the
here's how you make your partner a
minimalist
we will be uh yeah we will sell three
million copies just like marie kondo
[Laughter]
well i mean the thing about that is what
you're talking about is how do i get
this person to change their world view
right
and
what you're really saying is how do i
get them outside of their comfort zone
the comfort zone that we have is a
killer right and ryan is right that
these things aren't bothering him at
least consciously they may be bothering
him subconsciously sounds like your
husband is at least a
level one hoarder maybe even a level two
hoarder ryan and i even had some level
three hoarding tendencies
back in our
consumerist days a level one hoarder you
know what a level one hoarder means you
have light clutter in more than one room
yeah
yeah no noticeable odors
yeah that those are like the the key
signs no noticeable odors uh-huh so
light clutter in in every room yeah in
more than one room more than one room
and so clearly he's a level one [ __ ]
that's not a judgment right it's just
understanding that most of us
we tend to hoard we tend to cling and
you mentioned this earlier about the
desire to cling and and there are really
three reasons that we cling to anything
the first reason is we want approval
from someone or validation or veneration
i need someone to look favorably on me
the other way that we look at that is we
mistake it for love i want to be loved
and this often goes back to childhood
trauma in our lives right and so instead
of pointing and saying oh my husband
needs to change these things let's talk
about why he may be clinging to some
things that aren't adding value to his
life
because you can tell him till you're
blue in the face you should do this you
should do that here are the benefits i'm
getting
but that's almost like talking to him
about oh we're getting ready to go on
tour in canada we have two tour stops
toronto and vancouver coming up now
imagine ryan if we landed in vancouver
and i handed you a map of toronto
and said here you go
navigate the streets yeah right and
that's kind of what you're doing here is
you're handing him you'd be handing him
your map peg yeah here's the benefits i
get but he may not experience those same
benefits he needs a map of vancouver not
of toronto what am i meaning there what
i mean is he needs to understand what
the benefits are for him that's why we
started our last film with that question
how might your life be better with less
not how your life well and his life will
both be better with less
how will his life be better with
less helping him understand that because
fundamentally we cling to things for
three reasons one is approval i just
talked about that we feel like we have
lost out on love somewhere along the way
two is control
this was my big one especially as a kid
because
my world was so chaotic and it's still a
big one for me right now
it's it's part of my program part of my
childhood trauma because the world was
so chaotic i clung to the few things
that i had
because i needed that sense of control i
need to have control over something it's
also the reason i over ate and i was
morbidly obese as a kid i could control
the calories i was putting in my body i
control the gustatory pleasure in this
moment and third and finally
safety or security that's why we cling
we think that i'm going to be safe if i
have all the right things the control
thing is fascinating because
we
the more we seek control the less the
more things get out of control because
you can control all these different
variables yeah and then you realize like
oh now i feel like i need more control i
i witnessed this recently ryan i'm in
the process of moving right now because
i just bought a house and we'll talk
about that in a future episode we're
going to do a home ownership versus
renting episode in the future but
i'm great with chaos outside the home
i'm able to function really well with
chaos everywhere but in the home
it is crippling for me yeah it's that
control thing man and it goes back to
that childhood trauma right yeah oh if
things are out of control i need to be
able to control something right but of
course if i get everything in order and
have all the right knick-knacks and all
the things in place and i have
everything under control has it really
changed anything has it made me more
complete
no the default setting in our lives
is enough
the problem is we're constantly seeking
enough
outside it's like trying to count to
infinity
you can try to count to infinity
it's like trying to get enough yeah
infinity's already there you can't count
to it
enough is already there you can't get to
it and so if you're starting with that
state if
your husband peg if he understood that
he already has enough
then any of the things that he brings
into his life it's fine nothing wrong
with stuff peg you have some stuff in
fact you might even have some stuff he's
like i can't believe she has that thing
and that's okay
but we can bring those things in
and we can hold on to them as they're
useful
without clinging to them long term yeah
so i'm thinking about reasons why we
cling so there's just in case stuff
which would be that would fall into the
category of uh safety
and you know having something just in
case sentimentality does that go back to
the first one
so sentimentality is validation love
yeah i think that's part of i think it
depends on the person so we all every
human being has all three of those
approval mm-hmm we all need approval we
all need to control to some extent yeah
we all need to feel safety right
yeah we think that we need these things
right and it manifests in different ways
even the hanza they need to have control
of their environment to make sure
they're not being eaten by a predator or
something right and safety etc in fact
safety tends to govern those other two
um when we when we you really look at
the default there anyway
when i when i think about the just in
case item yes most of the time that is
well i feel as though
things are scarce yeah and because
things are scarce i need to control
scarce i don't have the abundance
mindset i have a scarcity mindset right
and so i need to cling to these things
to provide me safety or another word for
safety is what comfort yeah and as we
get bogged down in our comfort zone now
anyone listening to this has probably
had this experience especially if you've
shared our podcast with other people
that's our most popular way that we
reach other people certainly not through
advertisements obviously
people share it with their mother their
brother their sister whomever now you
might have heard our podcast and you
dove deep and you listen to half a dozen
episodes and you're like oh my god these
guys they're on to something this whole
minimalism thing it makes a lot of sense
to me and then you share it with your
with your mom or your daughter or your
cousin and they're like yeah
that's fine i don't really see what you
see in there now why don't they see what
you saw is because you were willing to
make yourself uncomfortable in the
moment you're willing to get out of that
safety and expand that comfort zone but
most people are perfectly content within
their comfort zone and you can't ask
them to you can't drag them out of their
comfort zone that creates suffering that
they didn't ask for right
but if they start to see the benefits
how might your life be better with less
how might your husband's life be better
with less because my guess is there's
some sort of childhood trauma or life
trauma in general that has caused them
to continue to cling
and with that clinging you get dragged
and he's being dragged in a direction
now that might be subconscious it may
not be like oh i realize i'm being
dragged i need to let go of this no it's
just suffering yeah and we hold on until
we realize
that we can
let go yeah
you know peg's question uh it's very
similar to some of the questions we have
today some of the questions we've got in
the past and really it's about
how to have a better relationship with
someone who doesn't have the same
thoughts about minimalism as you do
and you know i think that
and i know i was guilty of this having
this idea of finding like the perfect
partner
the soul mate someone who completes me
someone who
you know is just this this perfect
um perfect partner but the problem is
that there's no such thing as perfect
there's no such thing as uh you know
someone completing you
so
you know when when i hear questions like
this
it's like yes i do want to i do want to
make an observation about how maybe you
know the situation can be approached a
little bit differently to help ease some
tensions or you know cut out a little
bit of anxiety or whatever it is
but really
you know what i want people to
understand is like
it's not a question of how can you make
this person fit into your life exactly
the way you want them to that is a poor
quality question you're never going to
get there so the the real question is is
how can you work with someone towards
something that both of you can agree
upon
uh
that that path
that path is the that's that's in my
opinion that's the true path yeah and
what i'll say is that we imperfect
ourselves by trying to find perfect
external externally right yeah it's like
i'll just keep these things on to me and
they will make me perfect not realizing
like well i know i'm already enough
and to me enough is a type of perfect in
a way and then those things there's
nothing wrong with playing the game if
you want to buy a thing because it's
going to make your life
easier you know having the app on your
phone with the the music or whatever
instead of buying cds like okay that
that makes a whole lot of sense for me
right but it doesn't make me better it
doesn't improve who i am inside and i
love what you're saying about the better
quality question there ryan because
instead of saying how do i get my
husband to understand that he's
suffering because you can't there's no
how to understand right you only set up
the environment for understanding that's
how we learn through immersion and so
the better question is why is he
clinging to these things and it goes
back to those three areas either he
feels like he doesn't have approval
maybe that's from you or from his
parents or from society or he feels like
he doesn't have control and this is a
way for him to
regain control at least theoretically of
course that never works it never gives
us actual control the the best way to
get control to gain control is to let go
of
needing control yeah
and then finally if he feels unsafe i
doubt that's where he is so it's
probably one of the first two it's
either approval or the need for control
so get to the why then you can help him
better understand not through a how-to
but setting up the environment for
understanding did you enjoy this
standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free